[Music]
on this tuesday night a new cabinet for
a third term trudeau government
high profile promotions and demotions
everyone knows that cabinet making
requires difficult choices the new faces
and who's been shuffled out
what happens when mass mandates expire
we really need to have caution going
forward why doctors say it's important
to keep covering up
the parties on at huawei
the big bash to welcome back wong zhou
and the right to disconnect
one province's proposed bill to make
work leave you alone after work
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with some big changes in ottawa
prime minister justin trudeau has
overhauled his slate of cabinet
ministers there are nine new faces some
familiar faces are gone and there's been
some shuffling of senior portfolios
anita annan who led the procurement of
covet 19 vaccines becomes canada's new
defense minister and harjit sajjan
criticized for his handling of sexual
misconduct allegations in the military
moves to minister of international
development melanie jolie is promoted
from minister of economic development
and official languages to minister of
foreign affairs replacing mark garneau
who is no longer in cabinet stephen
gilbeau an environmental activist from
quebec is now minister of environment
and climate change replacing bc's
jonathan wilkinson who moves to natural
resources there are 39 cabinet ministers
in total abigail beeman looks at who's
in and who's out in our top story
tonight
it is a big shakeup with a
refreshed and reinvigorated team around
me i'm really excited about what we're
going to be able to accomplish for
canadians and i know
that this team is raring to go after the
election justin trudeau was already down
four female ministers he chose to lose
three more veterans jim carr bartis
jagger and foreign affairs minister mark
garneau out everyone knows that cabinet
making
requires difficult choices
nine new faces promoted to the inner
circle including alberta's randy bossino
popular nova scotia mp sean frazier
quebec rookie pascal saint-orange and
four mps from the gta some of the
biggest moves harjit sajin is out at
defense replaced by anita anand minister
anand has been extraordinarily effective
and one of the things that people will
be learning about anita anand
in the coming months is that she is a
world-class expert in governance sachin
is demoted to international development
he came under fire for his handling of
the various military misconduct files
that have rocked the institution
minister sergeant has consistently been
someone
who has been there
to fight for the women and men who serve
in our armed forces and to push back
against the culture i will put in the
necessary work for as long as it takes
to get this done as i have said i am
thorough i am determined i am dogged and
i am results oriented and i will be
dedicating all of my energies towards
this task this is not about my legacy
this is about serving the women amen and
the canadian armed forces
while melanie jolie gets a big boost to
foreign affairs minister johnny duklow
promoted to health replacing patti haidu
moved to indigenous services
there are new portfolios too ahmed
hassan is now minister of housing
diversity and inclusion bill blair's
role split in two he remains minister of
emergency preparedness while marco
mendicino is boosted from immigration to
public safety
a split at health too and a big move for
carolyn bennett who handled indigenous
files since 2015 she's moved out to
become the new minister of mental health
and addictions and associate minister of
health a lot of people i think have seen
that that mental health has become a
parallel pandemic
the new cabinet has time to get up to
speed with a month to go before the
house returns and they have more time
under justin trudeau today he gave a
very clear answer committing to lead his
party into the next election whenever
that may be donna and abigail what might
we be able to read into this new cabinet
and the priorities of prime minister
trudeau's new government well their
number one priority is the pandemic and
the liberals want to act quickly like we
saw earlier in the pandemic other
priorities include housing child care
the economy the environment and
reconciliation those are all reflected
in the picks for cabinet whatever
ambitions the liberals have they will
have to be collaborative if they want to
push their minority government's
priorities forward donna all right
abigail beeman in ottawa thanks to
explore some of the changes in cabinet
in more detail michael couture is with
me also from ottawa mike let's start
with melanie jolie her promotion really
raises her profile makes her this
government's fifth foreign affairs
minister in six years what's the
reaction so far well certainly raised
some eyebrows as she was given the
biggest promotion today especially when
you consider her federal political
career hasn't exactly been an easy one
she had some difficulties with the
heritage portfolio but then in
diplomatic circles she was credited with
helping canada save face at the summit
of the francophonie in 2018. jolie
negotiated an exit strategy for mikhail
jean who did not have wide support to
run again as the head of that
organization one former canadian
diplomat tells me jolie's appointment is
a clear signal to the rest of the world
that this government wants to once again
promote a feminist foreign policy so
what about her predecessor mark garneau
well he was dropped from cabinet and
it's unclear what will happen to him
there are some rumblings he may be
tapped as canada's next ambassador to
france and you'll remember four years
ago stefanzio moved from foreign affairs
and was appointed as the ambassador of
germany and the eu
jolie as you said donna will now be
trudeau's fifth foreign affairs minister
in the last six years and mike there is
a new minister of environment and
climate change as well stephen gilbeau
an environmental activist from quebec
former director of greenpeace what might
his appointment signal about the
government strategy on that file yeah
some inside the government believe this
will send a strong symbolic message that
canada is preparing to more aggressively
tackle climate change especially since
canada is heading to the u.n climate
change summit next week in glasgow now
in addition to being a founding member
of ekitail the agriculture non-profit
gibbeau sat on climate change advisory
committees of three successive quebec
governments now ask specifically about
how this will be received in the energy
sector prime minister justin trudeau
said that sector is already on board
with achieving net zero emissions by the
year 2050 and to help in that transition
we can't forget about the former
environment minister jonathan wilkinson
who has moved to natural resources now
with a background in clean tech he'll be
having those difficult conversations
with the oil and gas companies to help
them transition to a greener future
donna all right lots of work to do mike
locator in ottawa thanks the new cabinet
will put alberta's already tenuous
relationship with the trudeau government
to the test premier jason kenney has
said alberta is getting a raw deal and
he put the question of federal
equalization payments to a referendum
nearly 62 percent of albertans who voted
support removing equalization from the
canada's constitution edmonton banff and
canmore were the only places where the
majority of voters disagreed that does
not mean it will happen provinces can't
uter laterally change the equalization
formula and premier kenny himself was in
the federal government when the formula
was agreed to so what is this really
about heather yorick's west explains
the constitution alberta premier jason
kenney is calling it a win a clear
majority 62 percent of albertans have
rejected the fundamentally unfair
equalization program
in other words 62 percent of albertans
are demanding a fair deal in the
canadian federation
the referendum held last monday as part
of alberta's municipal elections asked
should the government of canada's
commitment to the principle of
equalization payments be removed from
the constitution
the thing is that's not exactly what
alberta's government is looking for at
all when you ask a question
to remove something from the
constitution something that you don't
actually have the power to do
but you tell people that you want to
mandate to negotiate it seems odd to me
instead the alberta premier wants ottawa
to renegotiate a program so that more
money would come back to alberta during
times of economic hardship a 180 from
the position he took as a federal
cabinet minister he also wants some
federal energy legislation the so-called
no more pipelines and tanker ban bills
repealed too the premier decided to ask
a non-binding question on a municipal
election in alberta
about an equalization formula of which
he was one of the authors when he was a
minister in mr harper's government
so i think it maybe you should ask him
what he thought could be achieved by
that particular referendum question
working against the alberta premier
within his own province the government's
popularity has tanked and within the
newly named federal cabinet there was
little to suggest alberta's interests
will be prioritized particularly when
stephen guibeau an outspoken pipeline
opponent is named federal minister of
the environment and climate change i
think it's more
trudeau doesn't care what kenny thinks
anymore a difficult position to be in
for a provincial government hoping to
force big federal change heather urex
west global news calgary
the rogers family feud that has captured
the nation's attention as having an
impact on more than just the family
analysts are downgrading the stock
concerned about how the company is
governed as ann gaviola explains the
fight is impacting the company's
reputation and that is spooking some
investors
everything i've done in my life
i've done for my children it's been
called canada's succession the real life
drama depressing rogers share price on
monday rogers common shares saw their
biggest sell-off since the market crash
at the start of the pandemic
the rogers family feud puts a spotlight
on what can happen in a company with a
dual-class share structure set up so
members of the rogers family who own
about a third of all shares control
nearly 98
of voting power at the center of the
battle edward rogers son of the
company's founder the late ted rogers he
was ousted from the executive board last
week after current ceo joe natalie
discovered a plan to unseat him
reportedly via pocket dial ironic from
the head of canada's largest wireless
player edward retaliated by setting up
his own board
we have two boards of directors
and you can't have that in a company you
can only have one edward's mother and
two sisters voted to remove him in a
tweet storm this weekend sister martha
rogers wrote i'll gladly blow up my life
to stop this edward is taking his fight
for power to bc's supreme court i would
not be surprised uh given the respective
deep pockets of the two sides of the
family
if one of them loses in the bc supreme
court then i expect it'll go to the bc
court of appeals observers say the
reputational damage is done what people
might remember in the next 10 or 15
years is not the incredible success of
the founder mr ted rogers but the
dispute that is occurring and if the
saga drags on it could jeopardize
roger's takeover of telecom rival shaw
which still requires regulatory approval
this has consequences for shareholders
rogers is widely held by pension funds
and in mutual funds
you can have family conflicts family
disputes
that
trump
let's call it
unbiased
impartial
strategic decision making there's a
growing push for ottawa to look into
whether dual-class share structures
should continue to be allowed in canada
other notable publicly traded companies
with this structure include bombardier
and shaw anne gaviola global news
toronto
defending the coup in sudan coming up
why the military's top general says the
army had to seize power plus queen
elizabeth cancels another trip
[Music]
there is more global condemnation after
the military takeover in sudan the
latest in what the head of the u.n calls
an epidemic of coup d'etat in the
african nation
protesters defied a military-imposed
state of emergency a second day of
demonstrations calling for the country's
democratic transition to continue and
today the army's top general said the
prime minister is being held at his
residence other civilian government
officials have also been detained the
head of the army claims the takeover of
the country's transitional government
was necessary to avert a civil war
the military and civilian parties have
shared power for two years and the
transition which may now be in peril
would see sudan come under civilian
control for the first time in more than
30 years
china has placed the city of longzhou
home to 4 million people under lockdown
the restrictions were imposed after 29
new cases of cobit 19 were reported in
china six of those are people who live
in longzhou residents have been told not
to leave home unless it's an emergency
with even a handful of cases china has
been implementing regional lockdowns to
avoid further spread of the virus
this is
returning to work at huawei's
headquarters in china she is the cfo of
huawei and the daughter of its founder
she spent nearly three years under house
arrest in canada fighting extradition to
the u.s and was allowed to go home after
reaching an agreement with u.s
prosecutors last month her return was
live streamed by state media
ahead as provinces wind down pandemic
restrictions will mask mandates be next
to go
[Music]
you're watching global national
[Music]
key advisors to the u.s food and drug
administration have voted overwhelmingly
to recommend the pfizer biotech vaccine
for children aged 5 to 11. the next step
is for the u.s centers for disease
control to review the fda's decision and
make its own recommendation its advisory
group is set to meet next week if
authorization is granted about 28
million children in the u.s will be
eligible for the vaccine the white house
says it has millions of doses ready to
be rolled out pfizer says the vaccine is
91 percent effective against covid19 in
children aged 5 to 11. in british
columbia a mandate is now in place
requiring all health care workers to be
vaccinated the province says most
workers have complied but there are four
thousand and ninety workers who have not
they will now be placed on unpaid leave
and must receive a first dose by
november 15th if they want to keep their
jobs unless they have a medical
exemption
as more people get vaccinated across
canada more places are lifting pandemic
restrictions mass mandates were slow to
be put in place in canada and now
there's discussion about when and
whether to lift them jamie morocco
reports
heart transplant recipient mike willis
can't just rely on his vaccinations to
safeguard him from covet i'm good with
people wearing a mask someone wearing a
mask
protects me more than it does them it
helps prevent the spread of droplets
which is
basically one of the biggest spreads for
covid mass mandates have been the
standard pretty much countrywide but
those protections are slowly being
lifted with plans to remove them in
saskatchewan next month and early next
year in ontario and possibly quebec we
also know that when we lose mass
mandates voluntary mass use goes down dr
catherine clace who runs a website on
effective masking says when that happens
kovid especially the delta variant can
surge we saw that in the uk and we see
the problem that they're having with
transmission in the uk right now and
we've seen it here at home in alberta no
masks and low vaccination rates caused a
near collapse of its icus doctors there
don't want to see history repeat itself
the question that we don't know is how
high of a vaccination rate is good
enough
to be a measure
as a stand-alone measure and i think we
really need to have caution going
forward
that
this is really a combination deal a
combination of vaccinating the next
eligible population kids 5 to 11
increasing hospital capacity tracking
coveted cases closely and keeping our
masks on masking should be probably the
last thing that we remove anything
sooner medical experts worry is a
political move without canadians health
in mind
jamie morocco global news toronto
queen elizabeth is not going to the cop
26 climate summit in glasgow scotland
buckingham palace says the 95 year old
monarch is disappointed about the
cancellation but she will still deliver
a video address queen is now back at
work after spending a night in hospital
last week doctors have advised her to
rest today she did hold virtual meetings
with ambassadors at her home in windsor
castle
the right to disconnect next one
province's proposed solution to ensure
work stays at work
in japan a member of the royal family
has married her longtime boyfriend and
lost her status as a princess princess
macco quietly married her college
sweetheart who works as a lawyer in new
york under japanese law female members
of the imperial family forfeit their
status if they marry a commoner male
members do not the couple has been under
intense media scrutiny and plagued by a
scandal involving borrowed money macos
says she is determined to build a happy
life with her husband
in new york
well the pandemic in technology has
changed how we work and for many people
the working day has been extended the
line between work and home life has
become so blurred some people never
really switch off now ontario is
considering a law that would give
employees the right to disconnect and
turn off during their time off
mike delay explains
it no longer matters where you are in
the office at home on the street in the
cold
that anxiety-inducing notification on
our phones will find us and at all hours
well leave it to france to start the
revolution which it did in 2016 by
giving workers the right to disconnect
after work it's an idea ontario is
trying to emulate
we're taking a side and it's the side of
workers it makes for a nice sound bite
but employment experts don't see how you
can legislate in a world economy frankly
it's it makes no sense at all let's
assume you're dealing with china
assuming you're dealing with taiwan or
north korea or south korea or any other
country there's a trading partner
you better not be disconnected at
nighttime because that's when they're
open i don't know how long we're going
to see this
seismic shift when it comes to um
employee empowerment but this sort of
quiet revolution we've seen to start
working from home adding in flexibility
that is going to continue still mario
zelaya likes the idea
when he started up bad axe throwing in
2014 his target wasn't the bullseye
it was to get away from 80 hour work
weeks in marketing expanding bad acts to
over 30 locations in north america took
work yet he did it with his own policy
of no business after five i find it more
expensive
to
lose people having to hire someone else
takes a long time seeing if they're
right fit train them build them up and
just burn them out like it doesn't make
any sense the market spoke to him and he
listened by turning off all
notifications
microlight global news toronto
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen your canada
tonight is a moment from the cabinet
swearing-in at rideau hall in ottawa
today algonquin elder claudette
commander asked the creator to bless
those taking on the responsibility of
being a cabinet minister here's part of
what she said thanks for watching
and i asked a creator
that the great gift that he will give
you
is that you understand
you embrace
and you walk daily with the seven
grandfathers
wisdom
love
respect
honesty
courage
humility and truth
and let us come together brothers and
sisters
let us raise our voice
in our heart with love
and together
let us say together that we acknowledge
the ancestors
that we honor the children
of yesteryear
today and tomorrow
for indeed we all know
that children are sacred
and we have a responsibility
to love and to care
and to ensure that all children
matter
and let us together say
miguel
merci thank you
[Music]
you